daar gaan we weer
meest gemaakte opmerking
zo'n verblijf is veel te vol voor een hamster
dat vindt hij echt niet fijn
hamsters zouden niet tegen drukte kunnen
hamsters zouden hun kont niet kunnen keren
en niet kunnen bewegen in zo'n voorverblijf
maar klopt die overtuiging wel die jullie hebben
op dit account
geef ik advies
gebaseerd op wetenschappelijk onderzoek
en de richtlijnen van de dierenbescherming
en het lcg dus
laten we even snel terugkijken
wat de dierenbescherming zegt over een vol verblijf
ik vind het altijd wel grappig
want wij krijgen altijd te horen van
je moet die bak niet zo vol zetten
want dan kan die hamster helemaal nergens meer lopen
en hoe zouden jullie dat uitleggen
waarom is het belangrijk om zo'n bak zo op de bak
vol te zetten
met verschillende dingen
veel beschutting en verrijking van hamster
hamsters zijn projecteren
dus die houden niet van open ruimtes
in het wild zou dat betekenen
dat die heel makkelijk gepakt kan worden
door een vogel bijvoorbeeld
dus zij willen juist overal
tussendoor en onderdoor kruipen
die beschutting is dus juist belangrijk
voor hun veilige gevoel
zoals jullie horen
zegt de dierenbescherming ook
dat het van groot belang is
dat je zo'n verblijf supervol zet
de overtuiging
dat een hamster genoeg zou hebben aan een dun
laagje zaagsel
een huisje een loopwiel
een voerbakje en een waterflesje is oude hamsterzorg
de oude hamsterzorg was gebaseerd op het idee
wat een mens denkt dat een hamster prettig vindt
vervolgens
kwamen er allerlei wetenschappelijke onderzoeken
waar ze achter kwamen
wat een hamster daadwerkelijk vanuit nature
zelf prettig vindt
en gebaseerd daarop is dit account
gebaseerd op die wetenschappelijke onderzoeken
gebaseerd op de informatie
die ook de dierenbescherming
en het lscg aan mensen geven
over diervriendelijke hamsterzorg
dus alsjeblieft zet je verblijf super vol
genoeg beschutting en verrijking
want dat is waar je hamster blij van wordt
doe je het niet ervaart je hamster enorm veel stress